[Aplausos]
hola a todos ya todas quisiera pedirles
un favor si la fila del medio pudiera
levantar la mano bien alto
si lo volteamos a ver esto representa
más o menos un tercio de la sala muchas
gracias
un tercio es un número importante
una de tres mujeres en el mundo ha
sufrido violencia física o sexual
una de tres mujeres en esta sala es una
sobreviviente de este tipo de violencia
de género
una de tres mujeres que usted frecuente
en su día con día
es una sobreviviente de violencia contra
la mujer
es un tema complejo sistémico y endémico
en nuestros países en américa latina'
en brasil en 2017
se reportaron 60.000 casos de violencia
sexual
esto representa un incremento del 8% en
comparación con el año anterior y de
acuerdo a organizaciones especializadas
en el tema
solo se reportan 10 por ciento de los
casos por lo que en brasil el año pasado
se estiman que hubieron 600.000 casos de
violencia sexual
en los países hispanohablantes el
problema es similar en colombia de
acuerdo a datos de la policía nacional
en 2017 hubieron 20 mil 28.000 casos de
delitos sexuales
esto representa un incremento del 18 por
ciento en comparación al 2016
imaginen todos los casos que todavía no
se reportan
en colombia cada día 77 mujeres reportan
un caso de violencia sexual
y más allá de las estadísticas estas son
personas reales que hacen parte de
nuestras comunidades son madres hijas
hermanas
amigas
y mientras es cierto que es un tema que
afecta también a los hombres y a los
niños afecta principalmente a las
mujeres
cuántas de nosotras cuando salimos a la
calle no pensamos en nuestra seguridad y
más aún cuando nos arreglamos
cuántas de nosotras no ha recibido una
mano ziada no deseada y quisiéramos
voltearnos a decirle a esa persona que
te pasa pero la pensamos dos veces a lo
mejor se equivocó no quiero armar un
escándalo
diario las mujeres tenemos que pensar en
nuestra seguridad física y personal
como muchos de ustedes estos temas de
violencia los he vivido desde joven niña
hasta mi vida adulta de mujer
de niña tuve que denunciar frente a la
policía si un amigo mayor que yo había
abusado sexualmente de una amiga en una
fiesta
de adolescente mi padrino me dijo que si
quería ser parte del mundo del
espectáculo iba a tener que practicar
sexo oral frecuentemente
cuando era estudiante trabajaba de
mesera tuve que presenciar
como un grupo de deportistas ebrios
acosaba verbalmente violentamente a una
de mis compañeras
y empezando mi vida profesional tuve que
abandonar la idea de trabajar más de
cerca con una consultoría prestigiosa
porque uno de los socios buscaba
pretextos para reunirse conmigo fuera
fuera de la oficina
entonces en cuanto tuve la oportunidad
de di que dedicar mi alma y cuerpo a
esta causa
y lo primero que me di cuenta es que a
pesar de vivir esta experiencia como
mujer no era un experto en el tema y
tenía que tener la humildad de escuchar
para entender la complejidad y los retos
que representa la violencia sexual la
violencia contra la mujer y por esto he
estado viajando por todas las américas
desde estados unidos costa rica colombia
brasil y méxico- he podido reunirme con
más de 50 expertos y activistas
organizaciones de la sociedad civil que
han dedicado hasta 20 años de su vida
luchando en este tema guerreros y
guerreras en vida real
es importante entender que el concepto
de violencia sexual tiene una definición
amplia puede ir desde una mirada lasciva
hasta un comentario inapropiado sobre la
vestimenta
hasta la penetración sexual no
consentida en orden de severidad pero
también incluye el acoso en el lugar del
trabajo o la trata de personas para
fines de explotación sexual y créanme
que independientemente del nivel de
severidad todos son violencia sexual
violencia contra la mujer
y de los datos que hemos visto esto
solamente es la punta del iceberg porque
todavía hay muchos sus registros
a las personas que han sufrido violencia
sexual es un proceso muy doloroso y el
tener que contarlo que denunciarlo
múltiples veces es volver a vivir esa
violencia
y en muchos casos son revictimizadas en
sus propias familias y en el espacio
público
cuántos de nosotros no hemos escuchado
no tenía por qué andar en la calle y con
ese vestido a esas horas estaba en una
discoteca lo estaba buscando
todos estábamos ebrios ella lo quería
esto no ayuda a los temas de sus
registros
y si por alguno de ustedes estaban
pensando pero también hay denuncias
falsas hay gente que se aprovecha de la
situación y que puede arruinar con vidas
es cierto pasa y no debería de pasar
pero también es importante reconocer que
de varios estudios que se han realizado
como en otros tipos de reportes también
hay denuncias falsas estos en los
estudios en donde los porcentajes más
altos es el 10% pero el promedio suele
ser del 2 al 5 por ciento
y es importante considerar que de estas
denuncias falsas también hay casos de
niños y niñas que al darse cuenta que
los podrían separar de sus familias
retractan su denuncia
durante estos viajes durante esta
investigación también aprendí que en
brasil los homicidios de mujeres blancas
está bajando y los homicidios de mujeres
afrodescendientes están creciendo
la violencia sexual la violencia contra
la mujer es diferente dependiendo del
color de piel de la edad del grupo
socioeconómico
y de la orientación sexual
y así mismo es diferente el que sean
escuchadas el que puedan contar su
historia y el acceso a la justicia
y esto tanto las sobrevivientes como los
perpetradores lo saben pueden pasar
muchos años sin que nunca se descubra
que una persona está ejerciendo
violencia sexual
puede pasar toda una vida y que esa
persona nunca sea descubierta
porque les cuento esto porque es
importante reconocer que no sabemos todo
sobre violencia sexual y es importante
contar y escuchar
gracias a la tecnología en los últimos
años hemos visto movimientos poderosos
como ni una menos imitó hablar de y
denunciar
desde el acoso callejero hasta el
femicidio esto alentado a millones de
mujeres a salir a contar su historia a
buscar justicia
como bien veíamos el tema de la
violencia sexual es un tema sistémico
complejo que afecta a todas nuestras
sociedades
y es importante que las historias salgan
para que podamos salir al mundo y
decirle esta es la magnitud del problema
y juntos hombres y mujeres salgamos a
decir ya basta y cada quien de nosotros
pueda contribuir a erradicar la
violencia contra la mujer
lo que aprendí de cindy software que es
representante de la red nacional contra
la violencia doméstica en eeuu es que un
primer paso importante para erradicar la
violencia contra la mujer es hablar del
tema
solemos cada uno de nosotros al momento
de una elección tenemos el poder de
cambiar el rumbo que toma un país
en el caso de la violencia contra la
mujer y la violencia sexual también cada
uno de ustedes tiene el poder de cambiar
el rumbo de esta tendencia
y lo interesante es que con las
oportunidades de votar no hay tantas
como las oportunidades que tienen
ustedes de charlar diario con sus seres
queridos al respecto
por lo que les invito lo primero que
hagan saliendo de esta conferencia si es
posible hablen del tema con sus seres
queridos con amor y empatía y con la
capacidad de escucha que se merecen
y lo segundo con los que les quiero
invitar es a saber clics si llegaran a
ver un caso de violencia sexual de
violencia contra la mujer tienen el
poder de intervenir
de acuerdo a la organización no más hay
tres formas de intervenir
la primera es distraer
si ven una pareja que está a punto de
estar en esta situación lo consideran
seguro pueden intervenir tratando de
cambiar la conversación con un tema
neutro
lo segundo es ser directo si ven a una
persona en un adentro alcoholizada que a
lo mejor ya no tiene el poder del
consentimiento pueden acercarse y
preguntarle estás bien necesitas ayuda
y la tercera es delegar si no sienten
que están en capacidad de intervenir
pueden buscar a una persona tercera
alguien más como un amigo o el oficial
de seguridad o recursos humanos
para que puedan intervenir en su lugar
es importante saber que más allá de lo
que como personas podemos hacer también
como personas somos miembros de la
sociedad civil somos profesionistas en
una empresa somos funcionarios públicos
las empresas estos grupos las hacemos
las personas y si unimos fuerzas podemos
ser más fuertes en este combate para
erradicar la violencia contra la mujer
quiero darles un ejemplo
como usada en el tema de la violencia
contra la mujer la violencia sexual es
un tema complejo sistémico que puede
suceder en cualquier lugar incluido
medios de transporte es un tema que debe
de enfrentarse desde diferentes ángulos
frentes distintos y complementarios
por mi parte como responsable de
operaciones de seguridad y confianza
para américa latina de uber junto con un
grupo de personas extraordinarias tanto
hombres y mujeres
hoy esta semana anunciamos nuestro
compromiso para contribuir a la lucha
contra la violencia de la mujer
y lo hacemos de tres formas y son formas
que ustedes también pueden aprovechar la
primera es apoyando a organizaciones
expertas en este tema
por nuestra parte estamos apoyando el
instituto igarapé en toda latinoamérica
empezando por brasil colombia y méjico
para que puedan hacer una investigación
y sistematización de datos de violencia
contra la mujer tanto a nivel nacional
estatal y ciudad también estamos
reiterando nuestro compromiso con la
fundación juanfe que muchos de ustedes
conocen para otorgar cinco becas a
estudiantes en situación de
vulnerabilidad que puedan haber sufrido
violencia sexual en su entorno
también estamos sensibilizando a las
comunidades con las que trabajamos
iniciamos una campaña de sensibilización
con nuestros socios conductores y
usuarios
asesorados por expertos en el tema como
hay cuál es otro mundo que es una
empresa líder global que trabaja para la
equidad de género debía erradicar la
violencia que se especializa en hombres
y niños
y tercero
trabajamos continuamente con la
tecnología porque somos una empresa de
tecnología en mejorar nuestros procesos
y la tecnología para que la plataforma
sea siempre más segura y prevenir este
tipo de incidentes y además para mejorar
nuestros procesos de atención de llegar
de tener un reporte de este tipo
son tres cosas las con que las quiero
dejar
todos tenemos el poder de contar nuestra
historia nuestra vivencia hombres y
mujeres y de escuchar
todos tenemos el poder de intervenir
frente a una situación delicada y todos
desde nuestras canchas podemos hacer más
para que las organizaciones en las que
trabajamos se comprometan a erradicar la
violencia contra la mujer
la violencia sexual no es un tema de
sexo
es un tema de poder
de acuerdo a naciones unidas'
una expresión de violencia de control de
humillación de las mujeres y está en el
poder de cada uno de nosotros en cada
uno de ustedes el poder de erradicarlo
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]